what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be taking the five love languages
quiz before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and please
subscribe because I want to hit a
million subscribers before New Year's
Eve that's a hefty goal but I think we
can do it so hit the Subscribe button
relationships don't have to be
complicated join the millions of people
strengthening their relationships with
the five love languages quiz I don't
want a complicated relationship so I'm
gonna start here okay how would you
describe yourself I'm an adult how would
you describe yourself I'm single it's
more meaningful to me when someone I
send someone I love sends me a loving
note text email for no special reason or
I hug someone I love oh that's a hard
one
um the text it's more meaningful to me
when I can spend alone time with some
someone I love just us or someone I love
just something practical to help me out
okay so this has changed over time when
I was younger I would have said that
someone does something practical to help
me out but the older you get the less
free time you get so I actually feel
like one-on-one time is more special to
me now it's more meaningful to me when
someone I love gives me a little gift as
a token of our love or concern for each
other I get to spend uninterrupted
Leisure Time with those I love
I'm just thinking would I rather go on a
date or get a gift probably go on a date
I would say it's more meaningful to me
when someone I love does something
unexpected for me to help me with a
project or I can share an innocent touch
with someone I love I would probably say
the project
because they always say you don't know
your real friends until you move
and I would say that's true shout out to
everyone that helped us move into the
penthouse though shout out shout out
um it's more meaningful to me when
someone I love puts their arms around me
in public or someone I love surprises me
with a gift I would say put their arms
around me because there's just nothing
like like a nice hug I don't know it's
more meaningful to me when I'm around
someone I love even if we're not really
doing anything or I can be comfortable
holding hands high-fiving or putting my
arm around someone I love
um I would say just being around like
it's just nice when you're in a
relationship just like spending time
together like even if you're not doing
anything just being around that person
is nice it's more meaningful to me when
I receive a gift from someone I love or
I hear from someone I love that they
love me
um
I would say okay in the early stages of
dating it's usually that they like it's
usually that they love me but it's like
I feel like when you've been with
someone a while like you kind of just
say that all the time so that it becomes
the gift so I would say the gift that's
going to be my final answer it's more
meaningful to me when I sit close with
someone I love or I am complimented by
someone I love for no apparent reason I
get gassed up from compliments like yeah
I would say the compliment
um it's more meaningful to me when I get
the chance to just hang out with someone
I love or I unexpectedly get small gifts
from someone I love I would say I get
the chance to hang out with someone I
don't know I just really like quality
time so it's always meant a lot to me if
someone like thinks of something that I
would like to do and they take me there
or even if it's just like watching a
show I like to watch or
okay I don't really watch TV but I watch
YouTube videos so they put on my
favorite YouTube video or something
um it's more meaningful to me when I
hear someone I love tell me I'm proud of
you or someone I love helps me with a
task oh that's hard
I would say in this case someone I love
helps me with a task because again it
goes back to it's hard because I feel
like I'm not answering these
consistently but it goes back to you
know you it's just so nice when you're
doing something and they don't even have
to ask they just help you like it's just
you feel so appreciated that you didn't
even have to like ask them to help you
it's more meaningful to me when I get to
do things with someone I love or I hear
supportive words from someone I love oh
that's hard oh I like both of those
things
um I would say that I get to do things
with someone I love because I just I'm
telling you it's funny because I think
if I took this test five years ago it
would have been the opposite but the
older I get the more I appreciate
quality time because again like life
just gets busier like you have more
things to do like for me and for other
people so it's just like the time you do
spend together you just learn to
appreciate more and that goes outside of
even romantic relationships like even
with my family like the older we get the
more everyone is scattered across the
country so you just appreciate the time
you do have with your loved ones I think
it's more meaningful to me when someone
I love does nice things for me instead
of talking about doing nice things or I
feel connected to someone I love through
a hug I don't hug my friends that much
like I'm really not that touchy but I
would say with a boyfriend it's more the
hug I would say the hug the boyfriend
it's more meaningful to me when I hear
Praise from someone I love or someone I
love gives me something that shows me
they were thinking about me I would say
the second one because I'm just really
into thoughtful gifts so I like it and I
think everyone you know does when it's
something that you didn't even it's
something that they get you that you
didn't even think about like all my
favorite gifts have been things that I
didn't even know I needed but they just
know me and they just really thought of
me like my mom she's a very thoughtful
gift Giver so every year at Christmas
like my best presents have always been
for my mother and I'm trying to think of
one off the top of my head I think my
mom got me like a photo album when I was
younger and it was very like thoughtful
and she wrote stuff in it it's more
meaningful to me when I'm just I'm able
to just be around someone I love or I
get a back rub from someone I love okay
I just like massages so I'm gonna pick
that one it's more meaningful to me when
someone I love reacts positively to
something I've accomplished or someone I
love does something for me that I know
they don't particularly enjoy I'm gonna
say the first one because I personally
don't and maybe this is an unpopular
opinion but I don't want someone to like
do something they don't like with me
um well I appreciate it I would just
rather like find a friend or someone
like I have a boyfriend and he doesn't
like watching The Bachelor let's just
say I don't even really watch it that
much but if he doesn't want to watch it
like I would just rather watch that with
a friend rather than him
um and then maybe find something else we
both like doing so I would say the first
it's more meaningful to me when I'm able
to be in close proximity to someone I
love or I sense someone I love showing
interest in things I care about ooh the
second you can get me talking about
YouTube for a while it's more meaningful
to me when someone I love works on
special projects with me that I have to
complete or someone I love gives me an
exciting gift definitely the projects
definitely the projects because it's
like when you have to get something done
there's just nothing like getting help
from someone especially when you don't
have to ask like it's just very
thoughtful it's more meaningful to me
when I'm complimented by someone I love
on my appearance or someone I Love Takes
the time to listen to me and really
understand my feelings I would say the
second there's nothing about someone
that's like a really good listener and
just makes you feel very heard um it's
more meaningful to me when I can share a
meaningful touch in public with someone
I love or someone I love offers to run
errands for me
um I would say the first because I know
most people don't have an assistant but
I have an assistant so I could just ask
her to do it
um it's more meaningful to me when
someone I love does something special
for me to help me out or I get a gift
that someone I love put thought into
choosing
I'm not a big gift person so I would say
the first it's more meaningful to me
when someone I love doesn't checks their
check their phone for a while while
they're talking or someone I love goes
out of their way to do something that
relieves pressure to me the second it's
more meaningful to me when I can go
forward I can look forward to a holiday
because I'll probably get a gift from
someone I love or I hear the words I
appreciate you from someone I love okay
I would say I'm just not a huge gift
person I'm more of like let's do
something together type of person so the
gift wouldn't be that big of a deal to
me and I just I don't really buy that
much stuff in general like I think I
spend the most on cameras probably right
now for my producer blessing
um but I just don't buy a ton of stuff
so and like even buying things in
general is like a hassle to me so I'm
just not a big gift person but I really
like experiences so if someone got me if
we flipped that oh but see I'm thinking
if it was concert tickets it would it
would completely change it you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna say the gift because
it could be an experience so I'm gonna
go gift but I'm not a things person I'm
like a what's a do something person
it's more meaningful to me when someone
I love and haven't seen in a while
thinks of enough of me to give me a gift
or someone I love takes care of
something I'm responsible to do but I
feel too stressed out to do at the time
you know I'm just thinking in real life
if someone did my accounting for me once
a month I would be so excited so I'm
gonna do the second I hate doing the
accounting I'm like three months behind
um it's more meaningful to me when
someone I love doesn't interrupt me
while I'm talking or gift giving is an
important part of the relationship with
someone I love oh this is hard because
sometimes I talk a lot sometimes I think
I need to be interrupted or if we did
gift giving but it could be an
experience I would do gift giving it's
more meaningful to me when someone I
love helps me out when they know I'm
already tired or I get to go somewhere
while spending time with someone I love
I would say the second I just really
like spending time with people it's more
meaningful to me when someone I love
touches my arm or shoulder to show or
their care or concern or as someone I
love gives me a little gift that they
picked up in the course of their normal
day I mean my arm or my shoulder that
just probably won't do much for me
someone touches your arm how meaningful
I don't know maybe you guys have more
intimate shoulder touches than I do but
I'm going to say the second it's more
meaningful to me when someone I love
says something encouraging to me or I
get to spend time in a shared activity
or hobby with someone I love second the
time it's more meaningful to me when
someone I love surprises me with a small
token of their appreciation or I'm
touching someone I love frequently to
express our friendship
um the second the second it's more
meaningful to me when someone I love
helps me out especially if I know
they're already busy or I hear someone I
love tell me they appreciate me I would
say the helping me out it's more
meaningful to me when I get a hug from
someone I haven't seen in a while or I
hear someone I love tell me how much I
mean to him or her
um I would say the second oh okay oh wow
I actually thought this was going to be
more because the first time I did it a
couple years ago I remember acts of
service was my number one but this is
exactly what I thought thought quality
time would be number one now because
again the older you get the less time
you have the second is acts of service
I'm not surprised because that used to
be my number one physical touch used to
be last and I think it's because this is
like if I'm with a boyfriend like I just
I feel like physical touch is going to
be higher than with my friends I'm not
that touchy with my friends
um receiving gifts I'm surprised
receiving gifts doesn't last but I think
it was because I put in experiences and
experiences kind of goes back to the
quality time words of affirmation I'm
surprised that used to be my second but
I think it's just the older I get and
the more I realize people say things it
doesn't mean they need them or their
actions line up so I think the older I
get the more quality time and acts of
service mean and the less like people
saying things means because anyone can
say anything especially on the internet
in Quality quality time and quality time
nothing says I love you like full
undivided attention being there for this
type of person is critical but really
being there with the TV off fork and
knife down and all chores and tasks on
standby makes you feel truly special and
loved distractions postponed activities
or the failure to listen can be
especially hurtful whether it's spending
on uninterrupted time talking with
someone else or doing activities
together you deepen your connection with
others through sharing time this is very
true yeah I think everything they said
was facts okay acts of service can
helping someone with homework be oh God
I'm just thinking oh God I hate math can
can someone how can helping someone with
homework really be an expression of Love
absolutely anything you do to ease the
burden of responsibilities Weighing on
as acts of service person will speak
volumes the words he or she wants to
hear let me do that for you laziness
broken commitments and making more work
for them tell the speakers of this
language their feelings don't matter
when others serve you out of love and
not obligation you feel truly valued and
loved that's your I think that's part of
the reason that I like I I love my dad
so much is because he's just so helpful
like that man yeah he's the most helpful
person I know physical touch a person
whose primary love language is physical
touch is not surprisingly very touchy
hugs pats on the back and thoughtful
touches on the arm they can be all the
way to show excitement concern care and
love physical presence and accessibility
are crucial while neglect or abuse can
be unforgivable and destructive
appropriate And Timely touches
communicate warmth safety and love to
you yeah I would say this is again this
is for me in a relationship because me
and my friends we really are not that
touchy but it I just feel like if like
if I'm in a relationship I'm more touchy
um receiving gifts don't mistake this
love language for materialism the
receiver of gifts thrives on love
thoughtfulness and efforts behind the
gift if you speak this language the
perfect gift or gesture shows that you
are known you are cared for and you are
prized above whatever was sacrificed to
bring the gift to you a missed birthday
or Hasty thoughtless gift would be so
disastrous so would be the absence of
everyday gestures gifts are heartfelt
symbols to you of someone else's love
and affection for you words of
affirmation actions don't always speak
louder than words if this is your love
language unsolicited compliments mean
the world to you hearing the words I
love you are are important hearing the
reasons behind the love sends you your
spirit Skyward insults can leave you
shattered and not easily forgotten you
thrive on hearing kind and encouraging
words you up I do still like when people
compliment me like I think anyone does
but the older I get the more I just
realize that the other
um love languages are a bit more
important this was interesting it's so
interesting to see how much acts of
service has gone down because it was so
high when I was younger and it's also
interesting to see how low words of
affirmation because that was my second a
couple years ago so this was an
interesting quiz make sure you guys like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel we're trying to hit a
million before New Year's so make sure
you subscribe ring that notification
Bell and I'll talk to you next time as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible